the giants need running back help with
saquon barkley on injured reserve after
tearing his acl devante freeman after an
extended
trip on the free agency
market now finally has a job he'd
visited jacksonville not that long ago
after leonard fournette was released and
it looked like it was over for devonta
freeman but necessity sometimes creates
opportunity and freeman
gets dumped right into the mix and may
get a chance to play fairly quickly
without barkley there shireen
it sure might you know they got wayne
gallman and dion lewis who are going to
kind of split the carries as they go
forward without saquon and devonte
freeman is not saquon we all know that
but neither are the two other running
backs they have on their roster but he
will help i think it's a really good
signing for where they are and and what
they need now his last thousand yard
season his last pro bowl came in 2016
and he turned down an opportunity to go
to seattle before training camp carlos
hyde of course took that deal that
devonta freeman turned down but he could
have had that job didn't take it so now
he goes the giants and he's going to get
a chance to play and maybe he plays
really well and
gets on the free agent market next year
and gets him a big contract who knows
but we'll see what kind of shape he's in
if he's ready to play
interesting to see how defense's game
plan against the giants without saquon
barkley do they drop everybody back try
to take away the pass and force devante
freeman to establish himself he may have
some opportunities to make an impact
right away with the new york giants
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports